today I will be matching people to their
Subway sandwiches all right so we've got
three sandwiches here we've got a foot
long spicy Italian on honey oat meatball
marinara Subway melt would you say you
are when it comes to food very
adventurous you can't be adventurous in
some way that's not true that's not true
because sometimes I put those like
peppers on there I'm like why did I do
this I'm not very adventurous
okay how much do you usually spend on
when you go to Subway yeah I'd say about
tax five to seven dollars I just feel
like the way you lifted this sandwich
like you knew what you were doing
I'm gonna go ahead and give you the
subway Mount and guess that this is
yours you know I threw you off a little
bit I do like a meatball marinara but I
also put a lot of vegetables on it you
said you weren't a vegetable person I
didn't like a whole veggie sandwich